This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is one of the episodes from the Phi
series.
Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
Before we do this podcast,
I would as I always do like to thank the
Scifi network for putting on the show
and Tim and Wayne from Saifai and frank
and Michael From and Todd as well from
the production company.
I had a great time with you guys.
You're all cool as fuck and uh,
I appreciate it very much.
The,
um,
episodes were filmed,
uh,
for the show and we recorded audio on
them to release as a regular podcast.
So,
uh,
that's why I want to thank a Psi Phi
for allowing us to put these out.
We decided that the best way to do these
podcasts was just to kind of have them
in the show.
There was like busy
work that we had to do,
like,
Dunkin,
I'm going to send you to
this place and you're gonna.
There was a lot of that stuff,
but the bulk of the podcast was
really just like a regular podcast,
maybe with some specific
subjects that we had to cover.
But Dunkin,
as always was fucking hilarious
and it was really fun to do.
Uh,
so I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought
to you by carbonite.
Carbonite is a way to back up your
files for businesses or you know,
you could use it for yourself to small
businesses rely on files saved for saved
on business computers like proposals,
contracts,
invoices,
contact lists,
all essential for running your business.
But finding the time to back
them up can be a pain in the ass.
That's why you need
carbonite online backup.
The same great backup that carbonite
provides for personal computers is
available for all the computers
in your business as well.
And once you have carbonite,
you will never have to worry
about losing your computer files.
No matter how many computers your
business has or where they're located,
carbonite backs your files to the Cra,
to the cloud securely,
automatically,
and continually.
It's great for a person like me
that I'm just not going to do it.
I'm just,
I need it.
I need things done for me.
I need it to be automatic.
And so carbonite is a,
a wonderful way to accomplish that.
So go to carbonite.com
type in the offer code,
J r e for a free trial,
no credit card required plus two free
bonus months with your subscription.
That's carbonite.com and the offer code,
J R E we're gonna use it to back up
all the files here on the Joe Rogan
experience podcast.
So,
uh,
we are,
we are endorsing it because
it is in fact awesome.
Enjoy The podcast,
ladies and gentlemen,
and a,
there are several more to come.
How many more?
We got left,
five or six left of these,
uh,
Saifai podcasts.
So with that said,
without further Ado,
ladies and gentlemen,
enjoy the podcast
experience.
MMM.
Yeah,
I,
it's certainly is possible.
When you look at the record
and you look at this,
a Homo Floresiensis,
this hobbit man from Indonesia,
when you look at the stories of
this thing called the Orang Pendek,
which is another,
um,
supposedly small hobbit,
like furry creature that's running around.
And then you hear the stories about
these gigantic [inaudible] creatures that
used to exist.
It's recently as a hundred
thousand years ago.
Yes.
You start going,
okay,
well there seems to have been a lot
of different kinds of primates then of
course,
is that Russian,
uh,
a ancestor of human beings.
It's found really recently that 41,000
years ago was a completely different type
of human,
was not a Neanderthal,
was not a homosapien.
It was something totally different.
Yeah,
and that's 40,000 years ago.
So you're,
it seems like as scientists
accumulate more and more evidence,
they're finding that there was a broad
variety of primates that branched off in
a bunch of different chains and it very
well could have been that there's more
than one intelligent one.
And it wasn't just human beings.
It wasn't just human beings,
Indiana talls.
It wasn't just human beings.
Neanderthals in this new
one that Dave discovered,
there might have been many more.
The problem with fossils is it's really
hard to leave a fossil when something
dies.
They just,
it just rots.
It gets absorbed by the earth.
Bacteria eats it,
animals eat it.
That's what happens to
most of us when we die.
When you find a fossil,
it's because something fell into mud or
got caught in a lava field or does it
has to be something really
weird that happens twice.
I remember.
Yes.
It's very rare for something to last
on this planet very long after it dies.
Yeah,
so our view of like what used to
exist is so weird because it's,
it's based on such a small amount of data.
Really kind of incredible when you
stop and think about what they have
discovered used to exist,
especially when we're in
regards to dinosaurs and all
the different animals that
have been extinct for
millions and millions of years
based on just this one way
of acquiring the,
the,
you know,
evidence of their body.
A fossil.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
And that they can reconstruct what
they looked like with some accuracy.
It is fascinating,
man.
And all of this stuff has shown
me how I'm a lazy skeptic.
Like you know how there's people
who just believe anything.
Well,
there's also the opposite of that,
which is people who just
disbelieve anything,
they don't look into.
Well,
why?
Why am I a skeptic?
Why don't I believe this.
This is the thing with people
who roll their eyes at big foot.
And by the way,
after going squashing with you,
I've gotten a lot of eye
rolls when I tell people,
yeah,
maybe,
maybe there's a big foot,
but in silver lake,
yeah,
and Silver Lake and all
you get is eyebrows.
It's like seizures.
If you tell somebody
you believe in big foot,
it's like watching someone on ecstasy,
their eyes go so far back in their head.
But
I've,
the thing I've realized is that a
lot of people will instantly say,
I don't believe in that.
And you say,
well,
why don't you believe in that?
And they'll say,
well,
because it doesn't exist.
And you say,
well,
why?
What's your evidence
that it doesn't exist?
And they don't know.
They have no evidence either way.
So I think that's an interesting
thing that I've discovered in myself,
which is that I'm an automatic skeptic.
When you would talk about
big foot in earlier,
podcasts are just on the
phone with me and my mind.
I'm like,
this is fucking horse shit.
Deep,
deep,
deep worship
with no reason to believe,
no reason to say that you,
he's having not an IG
investigated it at all,
having not even done a web search on it,
like really just not
even thinking about it.
And now I think,
well,
you know what,
I think that there is,
I think that it takes something a
little bit more than fantasy to drive an
anthropologist or a scientist or someone
who only has their career to ruin out
in the forest to hunt for
a mystical monkey thing.
I think that there needs to,
there's some evidence out there that would
make a person risk his entire career,
uh,
to come out publicly saying
that he believes in big foot.
Yeah.
Well this Homo Floresiensis,
the,
the hobbit man of Indonesia,
just stop and think about that,
that that was in 2005 was when
they discovered these things.
Just stop and think about if,
if someone said,
did you know before that,
did you know that 13,000 years
ago there was a type of human,
a really tiny one that was Harry and
sneaky and maybe stole human babies and
made its own stone tools,
but didn't grow any higher
than three feet tall yet.
Get outta here.
But it's the St Lord of the Rings.
Like you're making things up.
Yeah,
go roll some d and d dice.
Dark,
dark.
But it was real.
That was a real animal.
I know for a fact.
This is a bonafide real animal.
Buried.
It's dead.
Lived in tribes,
made stone tools three feet.
What is that?
Is that like that?
Um,
well,
it's my penis times three.
Three feet.
Yes.
Three feet tall.
It was a tiny,
tiny little guy.
I'm a little,
little,
little creature and
think about that to this
three foot creature.
It lived in a land of giants where people
would go lumbering through its forest.
This is a real thing.
This is people listening
to this right now.
It should just Google search this to
know that tiny little hobbit men once
wandered the earth.
This existed.
Yes,
it really did.
And very recent discovery.
Less than a decade.
Some people say they still exist.
Yes.
That's the other thing that there's a,
there's reports of them,
those islands,
there's,
there's so many islands in and around
that area and there are reports that these
things have been discovered on these
islands by people that have explored and
that the,
the local say they've seen
them and there's like,
again,
the Orang Pendek,
which is another tiny little hairy man
that has been reported being seen by
people for many,
many years.
So it's,
it's,
it's possible if you think of that,
the,
the size of them and then us and then
think of a big foot and then think of an
elephant.
I mean there's a lot of big things and
there's a lot of little things on this
planet and just because we haven't
physically laid eyes on a big foot,
we physically haven't seen a Sasquatch.
We don't have a real good
photo or a video of it.
Doesn't mean it's not real.
It doesn't mean it's not real.
And just because many of the people who
believe in big foot are several cards
short of a full deck doesn't
mean it doesn't exist.
Just cause it crazy person says it.
Thrill does not mean that.
It's not real sure.
I mean,
how many crazy people were talking
about this hobbit man and their minds,
but I'm sure he shared a
lot of people in that area.
We're saying if there was a smarter
man to tiny little furry man,
yeah,
bow and Arrow,
he be like,
get Outta here bitch.
Man Stole my baby.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
Right?
Nobody would ever possibly believe that.
No.
What,
what I thought was interesting about the,
uh,
the squashing,
first of all was that the guys who do it,
they,
I mean,
they take it really seriously.
Steve and John,
they set up camera traps.
They set up recording devices.
They,
they use thermal imaging.
they really take it seriously.
And if one day out of all this searching,
if one day they actually do
stumble upon one of these things,
what a glorious moment
it will be for them.
And it'll be a glorious moment for me.
I'll go out in the street and scream and
joy if one of those guys finds pick fun
and I would really hope
it would be those guys.
I mean,
even more than us.
I know it sounds like I'm being selfless,
but we don't deserve it.
And compared to the amount of time
that those guys are putting in,
they have full time jobs and yet they
have vans that are set up for squatch and
with solar panels on them.
And they mean they have this,
all these different pieces of technology,
camera traps and time lapse
photography things and audio recorders.
I mean,
they really,
you know,
they're,
they're really trying,
they're dedicated.
And we need people like that.
Look,
you're not going to get the most sane
people going out into the woods to look
for bigfoot.
That's hill.
Some evidence,
and then it'll be swarmed
with real scientists.
But if something happens and they
actually get some concrete evidence where
people are like,
oh my God,
it's,
we're dealing with a real animal,
then you're going to have teams of real
scientists that are in the woods and
those guys will get arrested.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
you know what?
They'll get in the way of the thing.
They'll quarantine the whole area and
all those guys will get hauled off.
But I will say this,
you know whether or
not there's a big foot,
if you want to turn a boring camping
trip and do a fun camping trip,
just gotten to the woods and
pretend that you're looking for big.
It's,
it's the renaissance fair of camping.
It's like go out there.
Just believed in the possibility that
there could be a big foot and start
walking through the forest
smoke some powerful Rogan.
We'd,
we probably can't talk about that,
but if you go,
I think that there is,
I think that squashing is the
renaissance fair of camping.
It's an imaginary way that you can turn
a boring camping trip into a thing that
has the potential to transform
human history forever.
And conversely,
if you go squashing and you're
unsuccessful at the very least,
you went camping,
you can't lose.
You went camping.
And I remember when I was a kid,
like when my parents would drag me
out in the forest to go camping,
I'd rather eat cyanide.
I wanted to sit in front of the TV,
watch TV,
be inside.
I didn't want to go out into nature.
I didn't realize how pretty
nature was until I'd take an acid.
But when,
if my parents had told me we're
going to look for bigfoot,
that would've gotten me out
of the house in a second.
It's a great way to go hiking.
That's the bottom line.
Squashing turns nature into a fun house
and all the wood knocking and all the uh,
the,
the different Howell's that
they do that sort of like,
it makes it like a fun game.
The gifting stump,
the gifting stuff.
And also the other thing about those two
that it showed me is how easy it is to
start a religion.
How easy it is to take a being that you
really have no evidence for and begin to
find evidence for it and things
that naturally occur in nature.
If you can't find a big foot,
if you can't find real
evidence of big foot,
you know what you can do.
You can attribute a feather in the path
to big foot having left something there.
If you can't find big foot,
you know what you can do.
You can say ravens are being sent by
big foot to watch you in the forest.
There's so many things
that happen naturally.
The sound of birds,
the sound of something falling out
of a tree that sounds like a knock.
Branches that have fallen
together in some certain way.
I hear it all right now.
Yeah,
it's,
it's easy and that's the exact same
thing that religious people do with God.
They've got this nonexistent being
that they have no evidence for.
A volcano explodes.
God is angry.
The rain doesn't come.
That's God.
The rain comes.
We've been blessed by God.
You know what?
One of the 200 told me what
this is essentially verbatim.
He said,
I was out near this blackberry Bush
and I started hearing this bull and I
was like,
what is a bull frog doing
near a blackberry Bush?
And I thought about it.
Lane Alley.
You know what?
I bet that was a Sasquatch.
Exactly.
A bull frog.
He said it to my face.
Yeah,
like,
like not like he was testing me,
you know,
he wasn't,
he wasn't being silly.
He wasn't pranking me.
No,
he wasn't seeing how far he could take it.
He actually said it to my face.
That's amazing.
And it's incredible when you realize
that priests are scratching for God.
Amazing.
They are a squash and forgot
and there's even less evidence.
Oh yeah.
Less evidence for God and there is for
big foot at least they have like gigantic
Pythagoras bones as if they had God's
big toe in a factory somewhere or in a,
in a museum somewhere in the Vatican.
A giant mystical toenail.
A giant God,
big toe.
And God for sure there was a god that
lived as recently as a hundred thousand
years ago.
Yeah.
Wow.
Big Foot is more realistic and religion.
Yeah.
There should be building
cathedrals to big foot.
I'd go to that church.
I go to the Church of
the squatch and a second.
Yeah,
it's all just would dock in and how Olin,
that was one thing that bobcat
Goldthwait film got right.
The Howells,
they're pretty bad ass.
Yeah,
no,
that was really cool man.
And I don't want to give away the ending,
but that was really cool,
man.
Yeah,
that last little part,
it was pretty bad ass.
I had to press pause a few times,
so that was so cool.
I love the fact that Bobcat
Goldthwait is such a big foot nut.
Look,
that's a,
that's another interesting
thing about big foot man.
It is a black hole.
It's a slippery slope.
Big Foot has gravity because once you
open yourself up to the small potentiality
a big foot,
you'll find your mind wandering
their weird parts of the day.
Just like
fuck.
And it's also like gambling where you
go to a slot machine and you think,
man,
one more quarter could do it.
I know I'm down 1000 bucks,
but one more quarter and I could hit
the jackpot this next squatch and chip.
Look,
I know I'm getting divorced
and I know I'm in debt,
but this one last squatch and trip,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna sell some stocks and I'm going
to go out there and I'm going to just
put it all on the line.
A two weeks squash and trip.
I'm going to get to the bottom of this,
change the world.
And also man,
I'll tell you,
there is a,
what's it called?
There's animistic religions that believe
that a spirit exists in every living
thing.
So trees have their own spirit,
leaves have their own spirit.
This is like a,
a very old way of looking at nature
is to see the thing is a living being
instead of just biology happening to
see it as one giant non-differentiated
living being.
And so there's always been
embodiments of the forest.
If you look at mythology,
you have pan,
you have the Jack and
the Jack of the woods,
which is this being that lives out in
the and as an embodiment of nature.
Well,
maybe that's what big foot is.
Maybe there's something built
into the human psyche that we,
when we get out in nature,
we project some thing out into the woods,
some human personification
of the wildness of life,
the wildness of nature.
Something that maybe we
lost a long time ago,
and that's what big foot is.
It's just this thing that human beings
long for their reminds us of the time
when we did you still live in the forest?
We used to be big foot.
That's what's wild about it.
We used to be this thing
existing in nature,
depending on foraging and
finding fish in the streams.
That was us.
So maybe that's what people see
when they're looking for bigfoot.
They see what we used to be.
That's a great point because when
you're out there in the woods,
like the Pacific northwest,
it's so just lush and rich
and filled with wildlife.
You start thinking,
could I exist out here?
If I was separate from society and
civilization and grocery stores and
automobiles and gas stations,
could I keep my body alive out here?
And I'm not sure if I could,
you know I've,
I've watched that show survivor man
where he goes out into the woods and that
guy is an expert survivalists and he
scratches buy for five or six days before
they eventually rescue him.
Yep.
And if,
if it wasn't for those rescue people,
eventually he would starve to death
and he's an expert survivalist just,
and he's got tools.
He's got like a pocket knife usually or
something that he can find and share it
together.
If you're by yourself naked,
like big foot
or think about your French bulldog,
imagine taking your French bulldog and
dropping your French bulldog off in the
middle of the Adirondacks.
How long would that French bulldog
survive without its wet food and it's chew
toys maybe,
maybe two hours before that thing gets
sucked up like a sandwich at a carnival,
that thing would be dead in a second.
And that used to be a wolf.
If you trace that genie,
the gene line of the French
bulldog all the way back,
you get a wild wolf and nothing that can
exist just fine out in nature is just
find out there on the same way.
That's what we are.
We made a trade off,
you know,
we lost our fur,
we lost the having tough feet and tough
hands and being able to climb trees.
That's the big trade off so that we
can sit and play x box and enjoy air
conditioning.
We lost it.
It's true,
but we used to be that we used to be big
foot and I think there's a thing inside
everybody that longs for that time.
If you trace big foot,
if you trace like the early hominids and
you go all the way forward to some fat
kid on Prozac sitting on the
couch playing call of duty.
Yeah,
that,
that's the same as a French bulldog.
Yeah.
If you could show a wolf,
this is what you're going to become
something they can barely breathe.
Breathe.
It's so
far.
It's all the time lies on
its belly and just fart.
What's a walking whoopee cushion.
It just farts and can't breathe.
Used to be a wolf roaming the wild.
Yeah.
Now it's not protecting your house.
It's not doing anything.
Now it's barely able to stay alive,
barely.
And you have to feed it and pick it up.
Pick it up to put it on the couch.
I want one man.
I've been looking for,
I want a squatch,
a mini squat,
you know a big one.
I mean,
I just having a squash in your backyard.
Nobody would ever try to break
in your house except the squatch.
Yeah,
we just feed them.
That would be an,
I would not,
you would do that by the way.
You would do that.
You've got like a pack of deadly pimples.
I remember when you bought all
those dogs and I ain't going to,
your house is terrifying and
you've got to play it cool.
Like you're not scared of
your giant death hounds.
My dog is a nice,
I don't have those dogs anymore.
Well,
what happened?
Didn't they all eat each other?
Well,
she fights.
Shit went wrong.
They ate each other.
One killed a couple of them
killed,
one of the other one
killed a couple of cats.
Man,
that was terrifying going to your house,
man.
That was scary.
When you got those dogs,
there's mastiffs,
those deadly,
massive,
massive suite.
He's not worry.
You don't have to worry about the master.
If it's the pit bulls,
no Mascara.
You don't have to worry about
the pit bulls or the massive,
but if you get two stone
dogs can tell that you're,
it's true,
man.
I went to my friend's house recently
and I'd eaten a little piece of this
chocolate bar.
I went to Johnny Pemberton's house and I
was like still stone and paranoid and I
went to his house and I walked in.
He's got just a puppy and I walk in.
I'm so paranoid that puppy looks at me.
He's like,
cause I'm scared as and sheer sweating.
You have like a layer of sweat slime,
losing a few like a fish.
It's just
shitting your pants and fear of a puppy.
I've got that southern lawyer,
armpits
today deal,
Tia and then,
yeah,
nothing that only amplifies the paranoid.
I have a puppy that hates
you because now you're like,
what's it see inside of me,
I'm going to see that sees
the darkness that knows it,
knows him a piece of
shit and it starts here.
Your,
you know,
your self critical parts to
start analyzing your own life.
And I'm like,
man,
it's knows I gotta pay
my gates or knows I suck.
Knows about my tax problem
off
in a massage parlor.
The dog doesn't like it.
Hates it.
And then dude,
that is fine with a puppy.
But when you've got a
drop in a massage parlor,
yeah,
that's fine.
The dog sees no problem with that.
It's a human issue,
right?
Yeah.
Anybody can pet a dog and jerk
it off and they don't.
They don't care.
The dog would like it.
Yeah.
If you can pet a dog,
he'll let you jerk him off.
Dogs are notorious sluts.
Oh,
there's entire,
hold on a second.
What are you doing man?
Do you know what you're doing here?
Do you know what show you're on?
We just missed this shit
would have been precious,
man.
This would have been prime
time jerking off dogs,
son of a bitch.
You ruined everything.
Talking about jerking off dogs,
something unusable completely.
Okay.
Um,
let's just wrap this up.
The,
the squashing was very fun.
The I,
the idea behind it is
very interesting and uh,
I,
I remain open.
I give myself a tiny
window of possibility.
I may be a 10% possibility that there's
a Sasquatch really alive out there.
But as far as my hope,
my hopes and dreams,
it's 100% of my hopes
have 100% hope and dreams.
I mean,
it's not something that I've abandoned,
but the reality of the situations bleak.
I think it's a bleak situation,
but I don't think it's as bleak as I
thought it was when I first went into it.
And that's to me,
very exciting.
What made you change your mind at all?
What made you expand the possibilities?
Meldrum
yeah,
talking to Meldrum because
when he started explaining,
uh,
the footage that you hate,
but he started explaining why
the thing would walk like that.
And then when he started explaining how
these footprints are very detailed and
then um,
when I put that together
with the information that we
found that there are these
little people that used to exist.
And then the thing with this ground ground
parrot that just showed up out of the
blue and all the new creatures that show
up out of the blue from time to time,
I just realized that it was very
prideful of me to just bugle out there,
no big foot.
I realized that for me to say that was
as unscientific as it was for me to say
that there is a big foot.
So I live in the mystery.
Okay.
Live in the mystery Dunkin Trust.
Yeah.
Live in the ministry.
I think they're going to wrap it up.
Aliens
does an alien.
The Sky above us.
Yeah.
Is Mexican without a green card.
That is weird.
They fly over.
I Dunno.
Huh?
Why don't Mexicans Flyover?
Don't have plans.
No,
but it seems like he's like,
you could get one is easy if you
get like one of those buses maybe.
But I think they monitor airspace pretty,
pretty closely.
All right.
Yeah.
You don't want to get shot out
of the sky by the federal A's.
It's weird.
That's fucking tunnels,
man.
Yeah.
It's interesting that we call people
from other countries aliens too.
Yes.
You know they're illegal aliens.
There's outer space
aliens and then there's,
but everyone who's not like your
country neighbor is an alien.
Yeah,
that's right.
Canadians are aliens.
Yeah.
It's so stupid because they're humans.
Like we act as though there's
some different being all together.
That's an old idea.
You know that if someone
isn't from your country,
they might not even be human.
They just look human.
Well,
the,
as the idea of calling them
aliens or alien to this area,
like an alien species,
it's been dropped into a lake,
like the snakehead fish.
That's been devastating.
These freshwater lakes because yeah.
It's like so hardy and eats
everything and destroys everything.
Yeah.
Kind of like what the white
people did in North America.
We're aliens.
Yeah.
We're the aliens,
but the American Indians
were aliens as well.
Native Americans came from Asia.
Yeah.
And the people in Asia came from Africa
and the people in Africa came from Maki
monkeys and the monkeys came
from single celled organisms.
Yeah.
Which came from bacteria steroid
that smashed into the earth.
So we are aliens.
Everyone's an alien.
Yeah.
Well if you follow that logic,
yeah.
Every single living thing is alien.
Because if that's,
if panspermia that theory of amino
acids and the building blocks of life
existing and asteroids and then landing
and earth after they slam into another
plan.
Yeah,
it's really interesting.
It's like a game of life leap
frog all throughout the galaxy,
all the way back to the big bang.
You don't even need the media or smashing.
I mean the earth is alien.
The earth came from some interstellar
dust that congealed at some point.
It's,
it all goes back to some flash of light.
So billions of miles away,
billions of miles away.
So yeah,
we are aliens now.
The way that our spaceship works might
be different from the white space.
Ships work on Star Trek,
the way our spaceship works as it
grows food and it grows people.
That's our space.
And we,
the space ship itself
produces the life form.
But to,
oh,
sorry,
go ahead.
Well to,
but to look at the wild insanity of
where we came from and then to be like,
oh no,
no,
there's no aliens.
Couldn't be not nothing out there.
That's madness.
If life emerged from the congealed
dust particulates that came from the
explosion of stars and the spinning,
the centrifuge action of this ball like
thing was able to spit eventually to
spit pinkies and brownies
out of the thing,
then God,
people,
there are many colors of people.
But to think that just that if our
planet is able to produce life just from
spinning really fast around a star,
to think that this isn't happening in
other parts of an infinite universe is
madness.
And then the real mind fuck is the idea
that our planet spawns this intelligent
creature that's insanely curious and
eventually starts playing with nuclear and
then anti
matter and then figures out
how to make a big bang machine.
And then one day one of them just goes,
fuck it.
I'll press it.
And he hits a button and boom,
the whole universe implodes back down
into the size of the head of a pin and
explodes out again in a totally new big
bang every 14 15 billion years or so.
Yeah,
and this is not that idea.
That idea is written about in the
couponing shots and the Vedas.
This is something they write about it.
They say that Brahmin,
it's a compared to an inhalation and
an exhalation that the universe is a
breathing thing and that sometimes the
universe expands itself in this infinite
outward breath and in that outward breath
all created beings form which are a
differentiation of this unit if field
of consciousness and then there's the
inbreath where everything comes back in
and forms back to that head of the pen
that science has.
The Big Bang is of course,
you know there are is
new ideas about that.
The whole head of the pan idea,
the condensed super particle that
they say created the big bang.
A lot of people wonder if
that's the case or if maybe a,
the big bang is the effect of one
universe brushing up against a universe.
And poking into it and creating,
uh,
the outreach of matter.
That is the big bang.
We really don't know.
Yeah,
that's a fascinating one.
The idea that there's parallel
universes like bubble baths that like,
you know,
the little circles in a bubble bath but
there infinite and each one of them is
its own self contained universe and they
collide and they're just millimeters
from each other,
millimeters from the other university.
Then they,
Ooh,
they collide and that's
her creates all the energy.
Yeah.
That's what it is,
is just an endless transfer of
energy from universe to universe.
Yeah.
That's,
that's what it is.
Just this giant living cluster of bubbles,
pea brains,
the idea of the universe itself
being semi infant or infinite or,
or,
or fractal,
the idea of there being infinite
amount of infinite universes.
It's just,
it's,
it's too hard to wrap our heads
around the fact that well,
it all also might be breathing.
It might be going out,
expanding and then contracting.
Yeah.
For Infinity.
And that thing that
you were talking about,
the,
the way that we explore,
the way that we have this desire to
understand and to investigate and examine
did.
That's the original impulse.
It's just that impulse is being channeled
through our particular neurology's,
but that impulse is in all living things.
That desire to experience and to explore
and to learn that this is this giant
massive bubble cluster of intelligence
is God trying to understand what the fuck
is happening because everybody acts
like God knows everything already.
Just think so.
If it's God,
it knows everything.
Why?
Maybe it's just like us only a trillion
billion to the trillion squared,
a times more aware and even
that much more confused.
Well,
how about one grader?
How about whence intelligent life
eventually reaches a point where it can
control all matter and has access to all
the knowledge in the universe itself.
Maybe it becomes God and maybe that's
what God is in the first place.
And maybe this coalescence,
this sin synergistic thing
that's happening right now
with humans and technology
is because technology is the only way
we can ask you actually become God
biologically,
is that we have to figure out a way to
manipulate matter to the point where we
take what we call consciousness and
put it into something that can develop
infinitely faster than
our simple biology can.
And that that in turn becomes
a universal consciousness.
And that that is the origins
of the universal consciousness
is not just that we
share space and that we
share this morphic field,
but in fact that all of our minds will
eventually join as one super mind.
And that super mind will
be the very creator of the
universe that has spawned us
itself.
Yes.
And that will be some 14 year old squid
alien playing a super advanced x box
going off on top of a windmill.
Yeah.
And that's all folks.
No,
man,
I,
I that,
that um,
that idea is really cool.
This is an idea Alan Watts
talks about when he says,
imagine if you could experience everything
like imagine if you were some kind of
godlike being in anything
that you could think.
You can instantly create
anything you want to do,
experience.
You could instantly experience.
If you wanted to know what
it was like to be everything,
you could feel that if you wanted to know
what it was like to be an alien flying
through space,
exploring space,
you could be that,
but eventually,
eventually Alan Watts says,
you would get so bored of being able
to do anything you wanted to do,
that you would be like,
hm,
I wonder what it's like to not
know that I can do everything.
I wonder what it's like to think I'm
going to die and be completely limited.
And then that's when he turned into a
human being and that's when you get it
because of the experience.
Human life,
we're like,
Whoa,
fuck,
I'm going to die.
You can't do anything,
man.
Oh God.
And then when you die or
when this event happens,
where everything unifies them
becomes one consciousness,
that's when you wake up again.
I'm like,
wow,
that was nuts.
I thought I was going to die.
I thought I was limited.
I thought I was an individual.
I thought I was singular.
As it turns out,
I'm everything and the whole
cycle starts over again.
What I found fascinating in
researching aliens and in,
in doing the show is the different
attitudes about what aliens would be
interested in and what aliens
wouldn't be interested in.
I,
the guy I talked to from Seti,
he seemed to believe that they wouldn't
even care about the fact that we have
nuclear power.
Like why would the aliens hover over
nuclear power and other people think that
that would the number one
thing they would concentrate on
and then other people think the,
well they had,
they would have access
to stop all that stuff.
They can control all the power and
they are essentially waiting for us.
This is like the most utopian concept.
Yeah.
They're waiting for us to graduate.
So a our society and civilization
stops being this fear mongering warlike
culture and we graduate to this next
level of spiritual evolution and join the
Galactic Federation that we become worthy.
And then they're sitting there
waiting for us to graduate from
high school.
Oh,
I love that.
That's really cool man.
Like,
like they're gardeners,
you know,
they're like planetary gardeners and
that human species is a form of biomass
that they like to cultivate.
And sometimes the garden grows,
sometimes it doesn't grow,
but it's some point,
the thing inevitably gets to a place where
it's about to blossom and that's when
it's at its most fragile point in time,
that place where it's about to grow
the flowers of the singularity or the
flowers of some super advanced technology.
And when that happens,
that's the joining of the Galactic
Federation that they is a new age crystal.
People talk about,
I think that's a beautiful idea.
I think it's a beautiful
idea and I think that I,
I don't see why not.
I mean we grow flowers,
we,
we cultivate the earth,
we breed animals.
Why wouldn't some super
advanced intelligence take
the light and turning monkeys
into flying teleporting
super technological beings.
Yeah.
And W we also have this thing where
we want results like right away.
You know,
we want things to happen right now.
Why don't the aliens land now?
Why don't people get
it together right away?
Why do we have to continue our,
our,
our primitive ways and
our primitive culture?
But if you thought about it from
the standpoint of an infinite being,
the why would the infinite being want
to rush things as all the time in the
world?
Like why does it need
the results right away.
Exactly.
And isn't there.
This isn't their joy in,
in the the struggle and this isn't their
joy in the whole process of becoming
this,
this symbiotic,
this God creature.
Yeah.
He's in the joy in all of,
it's slowly improving.
Like you don't want to have
sex in a 10th of a second,
you know,
a 10th of a second Sachs,
right?
You want to have sex for a long
time so that you can enjoy it.
You want your wife to feel good,
you want to hold in your orgasm as
long as you can for it to feel good.
Yeah.
And maybe that's sort of the same
idea about the universe creating
consciousness,
is that the universe wanted us to slowly
over the course of billions of years,
go from sludge that wiggles to people
that press buttons and rockets fly through
the air with nuclear bombs on the end
of them that literally splice Adams and
destroy matter instantaneously leaving
the area impossible to occupy for
hundreds of thousands of years.
But to the universe,
what's a hundred thousand years?
That's nothing.
It's a joke.
Nothing.
And this isn't,
you know,
in Hinduism they,
when they talk about the gods that they
all say like a day of Brahmin is like,
you know,
a million human years,
like one day for this being
as a million billion years.
So a super advanced being,
who knows how long the thing survives.
It's a great way to look at it too.
It's just interesting how humans tend to
ascribe cumin characteristics to beings
that emerged from ostensibly different
galaxies or even other dementia.
Okay.
Or even the universe itself,
the limitations of birth and death are
applied to the very universe itself and
really sorta arbitrarily just because
of the fact that they have the signature
from the big bang.
That doesn't,
doesn't mean it's not an infinite
number of those that have been going on
forever and there's no birth and death.
It's just that breathing
in and breathing out,
but everybody talks about one
day even our son will die.
Yes.
Will it really?
You know it,
it will create humans,
man.
Yeah.
The only way you can make
a human being as a star,
as to explode where we are literally
made out of carbon and carbon comes from
stars and all the,
the different matter,
the,
the different elements of matter
that make up a human being.
You literally have to
have a star that blows up.
So the idea that our stars going to die.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Our star is going to blow out human seed.
Yeah,
there you go.
Exactly.
You know,
our star is going to radically change and
the same way that everything radically
changes,
which is why death itself is a silly word.
You know when people say die,
really what they mean is the person,
the being,
whatever it is,
has transformed into something completely
different than what it was before and
that,
I mean,
I know there's a biological principle,
died,
death.
They say it's when we stop breathing or
that when we stop [inaudible] when we,
when we stop breathing and your dad,
but the reality is when
you start breathing,
really what's happening is you are
transforming into energy for all the tiny
little microbes living inside of your
intestines that are gradually going to
turn you into soil that's grown up,
going to grow food for
other people to eat.
You're not the not,
we have a dual,
the Dunkin,
we're going to formaldehyde people to
preserve them and they would code them
with a stick skin of makeup.
It's very lifelike and realistic with
a tow of subtle wax like quality to
grandma's face.
Isn't that hilarious?
I was just thinking about that,
like how funny it is that
we put people in coffins,
which are essentially supposed to
be beds so that people can like rock
comfortably and some kind of
like big underground couch.
You know,
how much space we could save in graveyards
if we have the guts to chop people up
and put them into little bags.
We don't do that.
Well how about put them into the ground
and have them do what they're supposed
to do in the first place.
You know why we can't do that?
Because we want to be able to dig
them up and charge people with murder.
Yeah,
exactly,
man.
That's right.
And also if we did that,
there would be a swarm of goth kids
descending on every grave yard just to try
to dig a skull outs.
They didn't have to bother
with pop in a coffin open.
But it is weird that we don't like
think of the shape of a coffin.
Right,
right.
We don't put,
if you wanted to save space in a cemetery
and you could dig a hole deep where
you could drop the coffin down,
like they're standing up
and you want them to relax,
we want him to relax in a nice bed.
I just saw this ad,
uh,
this old vintage ad for,
um,
uh,
a type of vault.
It's like,
it's an old drawing of a woman who's
standing by the window looking out at the
rain and it's like,
don't you feel comfortable knowing that
your loved one is safe from the weather
and evolve that like,
oh,
let water in there.
But that's it.
That's been going on forever.
And that's what pyramids are there.
Just elaborate ridiculous mechanisms to
try to preserve the human body sort of
then a mom know what the
hell pyramids are for.
Well,
they modification process.
Yeah,
sure.
that's,
that's a fascinating Todd.
You know,
you're not on camera,
right?
How dare you.
Um,
this skin Walker ranch thing,
we're going to go and we're going to,
there's,
there's a place in Utah,
it's called Skin Walker
ranch and this place,
it's legendary in the,
in,
in the the big foot folk.
Yeah.
Talk.
The,
the people that are fascinated with big
foot say that this is the spot where
there's all these different
things being worked on,
that there's wormholes there and
space ships are coming from wormholes.
So I go to their website,
right.
I'm thinking it's probably
just a regular ranch.
Everybody's just being nutty.
It's beans.
They have a link on the
website that says the entities,
what says classifying creatures
at skin Walker ranch out at work.
So I'm like,
okay,
now you got me.
What is that?
So I click on that and it takes me to
all the various types of entities that
have been reported.
Oh yeah.
And it is simple as the
spotlight and flashed drones,
a pulsating spherical ball of light,
which could easily be ball lightning.
Seems like these are like reasonable
sort of either a mythical explanations of
natural phenomenon or just legend.
So as we go further and further though,
it gets to weird ones
like the bulletproof wolf.
Ah,
yeah.
It says the dire wolf,
like creature as long dirty mangy
gray black hair has a proud,
intimidating and intense like presence.
At this time,
I am unsure if it is hostile or friendly.
My impression was neither more
majestic and to be in nature.
Wait a minute,
is this,
this is on the Internet.
Yeah.
My impression was neither that you're
supposed to have a comma dummy.
If you're gonna talk about fucking,
if you're talking to folks
at medical group wolves,
you don't have to use appropriate grammar.
May travel within the flash drones
and manifest from them as seen by two
researchers.
Oh,
as seen by two researchers
should be legit.
A bulletproof wolf that
comes out of a flash drought.
Well,
two guys saw and Dunkin.
I mean it sounds like these people are
just going around with a microphone and
recording.
People snorted bass.
Here's one of them.
The controllers would,
sounds like two adult males speaking
to one another in an unknown language.
These two males are typically
invisible and usually overhead.
Overheard speaking about
20 feet above one's head.
They are speaking in a
native American like dialect.
By the way,
that's also where they
attribute to big foot.
Yeah.
It's always like a native American
native American is the way to go.
If you want to go spiritual
and woo woo and you know,
you know,
if you want to share,
we want to talk to the spirits of the sky
in this space and we are in touch with
the spirits of the great
guardians of the universe.
So it's like a native American.
But it is funny that they're saying
that these beings talking to dialect,
which means that they're not talking
in their native language when they're
hovering above you,
they're talking and I,
and a language you understand.
Well not only that,
it means that there so intelligent,
so advancing,
get here from other planets,
but they haven't figured out how
to talk without language yet.
They haven't figured out how to
direct communicate mind to mind.
Well,
I don't think skin Walker
ranch is all about aliens.
I think it's just about a lot of
paranormal activity that happens.
And this guy talked to you and Austin,
Dr. Eric Davis used to
work there and this guy,
uh,
though I would say that he's eccentric.
He did a few things.
Uh,
when I went to visit him,
that made me think,
oh,
I don't,
I don't think that this guy's a Kook.
When,
and what he did specifically was,
um,
he has his laboratory where they're
doing all these various experiments.
This is a guy who actually
trying to create a warp drive.
He's trying to create a way using vacuum
technology to bend space and time that
creates kind of like a wave effect
that his ship could ride on a crest of
somehow going faster
than the speed of light.
Um,
so what,
when we went to visit this guy,
he did two things that made me,
do you think,
wow,
I don't know.
I don't know if how skeptical
I should be about this guy,
which is the ad is all these
experiments running in this laboratory.
One of them being,
they're trying to discover
a way to do cold fusion,
you know,
which is what somehow um,
creating an infinite energy source,
which is a,
what he calls a disruptive
technology or disrupt human society.
If we had an infinite energy source.
But what he did was he kept pointing
to his experiments and saying,
this isn't working.
Nothing's happening here.
This cold fusion isn't working.
And all of his experiments,
he was like saying we're all getting
no results from these experiments,
which me is the opposite of what all the
other Kooks that we've encountered on
the show.
Do people you like whoever
designed this website,
you,
you could probably call this person up
and say you saw an skin walker ranch at
tap dancing clown.
They can shoot lightning bolts out of
his hands that turned into pineapples and
that would show up on the website
and four minutes probably.
Probably.
Cause that researcher has discovered this.
No Sir.
We should try that.
Yeah,
you could get it up there.
We should see how many we can get on
there before the guy starts catching on.
It's a giant,
but literal holes through the hills.
You have to watch for it in your face.
Yeah,
it's it.
Yeah.
But it's farts have a
native American dialect,
a native American quality,
the smell like hickory,
hickory wood chips.
Um,
but this Dr. Eric Davis,
he worked on skin Walker ranch because
skin walker ranch is a place that was
bought by this eccentric guy named Robert
Bigelow who's currently working with
NASA.
He's uh,
develop some kind of inflatable
technology where you can add,
uh,
add onto the space station using like
essentially like super powerful bouncy
houses.
You know what I mean?
Like you like bill using metal and space,
getting metal in space,
getting construction material in this
space are using terrestrial construction
methods in space is not
only highly inefficient,
it's incredibly dangerous.
You have to go into,
to spend whatever amount of time it
would take to actually build things using
aluminum or metal.
It's dangerous.
So this guy came up with a brilliant idea
of having packaged inflatable a crafts
that you can bring in to space,
uh,
and the material that they're made
of is a much more powerful and can,
uh,
take the damage of micro media rights a
lot better than metal according to Dr.
Eric Davis since that's what Bigelow,
that's one of the things
he's working on right now.
In other words,
he's not just a a Kook.
He's actually got satellites floating
in space right now that he got up there.
So he heard about the skin walker ranch,
heard about all the paranormal activity
that was happening there and decided
that he would buy it since
scientists there to study it,
to find out if he could find any proof
of this insane stuff that so many people
are reporting.
And Dr. Eric Davis spent time there
studying this stuff and he said,
he told me to my face that he saw,
uh,
orbs floating out there,
that he saw orbs floating out there that,
uh,
he couldn't think of any
other explanation for.
I asked them about the cattle mutilations.
He said,
no,
that's,
he thinks they think
that's people doing that.
They don't think it's aliens.
He said that some of the researchers,
they reported seeing like wormholes
opening up and I this guy,
like I believed him.
Like he,
he actually gets contracts from the
government to work on this stuff and it
doesn't serve any purpose to go on a TV
and talk about wormholes opening up when
he said like,
I uh,
these researchers reported some kind of
creature emerging from this wormhole.
I mean,
I don't understand what you have to gain
as a scientist by saying things that
sound like they're coming from
the freakout tent at burning man.
It,
you know,
there's nothing to gain.
What do you have to gain if
you're actually trying to get,
trying to get business as a scientist.
So it,
when I asked him this,
uh,
one of the really smartest things
he said is that as a scientist,
that's your job.
You report your observations.
You have to say what you've seen.
And sometimes reporting your observations
means that people are going to try to
discredit you.
People are going to say,
you're crazy.
People are going to,
uh,
you're going to lose a lot of face and um,
I dunno,
I believed him.
There's also the reality to consider the,
there's a lot of people that tend
to lean towards the fantastic,
they tend to lean towards fantasy and
they want there to be something magic out
there and their regular
life is boring man.
They're,
the wife doesn't want
to have sex with them.
Their dog doesn't care.
There's nothing going on.
I don't really go outside if the dog,
the guy is there or not,
you know what I mean?
Cause like a lot of people that
don't have anything exciting.
That's my point.
My point is that there's a lot of people
in this world that they have no joy.
There's nothing exciting
about their occupation.
Sure.
It's nothing exciting
about their marriage.
There's nothing exciting
about their neighborhood.
They long for something special.
And I think a lot of that goes back to
our hunter gatherer routes where every
day was filled with peril and excitement.
And even though there was a lot of loss
of life and people didn't last as long,
it was still a lot of thrill.
You know,
people starved to death.
But you know what,
sometimes they didn't and you've got an
elk and everybody ate and they got by
the fire and you found mushrooms and
everyone took them and there was joy and
excitement and it was a real,
it was a special existence.
We've,
in making everything so safe,
we've Kinda like smooth all the rough
spots that could trip you up in this life.
We've also cut out all the fun,
you know,
we've,
we've cut out all the excitement,
we've cut all the worry about
getting eaten by a Jaguar.
The worst thing you have to worry about
as another idiot human slamming and you
have with their stupid car.
That's what Jeff to worry about.
And eventually we'll figure that out too.
We'll have some magnetic
field around each car.
So they repel each other like magnets
when you get close and they just bounce
off of each other.
That's on the way,
I guarantee you that's on the way.
Yeah,
sure.
I mean,
I think that there are a group of people
who just get super bored and make up
stories.
Kids do it.
Why wouldn't they make up stories?
But they lean towards the fantastic
say there's an infinite amount of
possibilities to explain any particular
scenario they're experiencing.
They lean towards the most
fantastic of those possibilities.
And then they nurture that and then
they also surround themselves with other
people who likeminded and
then they develop this sort
of hive mind of bullshit.
And they all sit around
jerking each other off,
pretending they're being
abducted by aliens.
Oh,
he's touching my bud abducting me.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
I'm touching your butt.
I agree,
man.
I think you're right.
I think there are clusters of psychos
out there and it's easy to find it.
So many examples of that
and I think kids tend to do,
I can remember and I as a kid going into
the house and telling my mom that I'd
seen wonder woman,
no reason to tell her that
I hadn't seen wonder woman.
I just like,
but I started lying to my mom.
I'm like,
yeah,
I saw wonder woman by how old were you?
I as 17
no,
no.
I was young,
man.
I was like,
you know,
six maybe I don't,
I don't know.
I was young,
but I can remember telling
this blatant lie to my mom,
my mom being like,
are you sure you sound wonder woman?
And then I started in my mind,
I started like imagining the
encounter to help the lie.
I could like kind of imagine the
wonder woman coming up to the plate,
to the,
to the swing and like saying hi.
I could kind of see you're
standing there and I,
instead of being like,
you know,
you're right,
mom,
I'm lying.
I just went deeper and
deeper end of the lie.
That's the problem with people.
It happens.
But I guess when I hear that someone has
taken the time to figure out a way to
construct inflatable space habitats and
has even managed to get those into orbit
and these,
and this is a person who has bought a
ranch where other scientists who are our
reporting activity.
When I hear that stuff,
I,
it makes me believe it a little bit more
than when I hear somebody who's just a
crystal gazer yapping about this stuff.
When I hear that stuff and when I hear it,
skin Walker ranch,
you can't get in there.
When I hear that they have
really high security and that,
you know,
there's reports of like government
cars going in there and stuff.
Then to me,
I start thinking,
well,
something must be going on there.
I don't understand why a guy is getting
million dollar contracts from NASA
suddenly decides to buy a ranch and put
a security perimeter fence around it
where people can't get into and then
become secretive about this stuff that's
happening in there.
Why if you're some line Kook who just
wants people to believe in aliens,
why wouldn't you just
send reports all the time?
That website you're looking at,
that's not Bigelow's website.
That's somebody who thinks he's
an expert on skin Walker ranch.
That's not Bigelow.
That's somebody completely different.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Well,
just to play devil's
advocate about Bigelow,
let's just assume that he's working
on top secret spacecrafts that there.
Sure.
Why wouldn't he have high level security?
Well,
you don't want people wandering up.
Hey Man,
what's your Weldon?
Yeah,
why you putting together a stealth bomber?
Right.
Well,
well it's not just that it's that he
bought a ranch that prior to his ownership
that people who live there,
we're reporting on this seven,
their cattle were getting like
regularly like Moodle and mutilated.
So there's some odds and not only that,
but he invited,
you know,
scientists there to
actually study this stuff.
I will tell you the part that makes me
skeptical about it is a every encounter
that Dr. Eric Davis reported,
somehow the cameras didn't work.
He said that he saw these floating lights
and it was filmed on security camera
footage.
I asked him where the footage was.
He said,
it's in some warehouse there and
Bigelow doesn't want to release it.
You know,
it's a classic thing,
which is you,
the you,
the person can report these experiences.
But you would think that scientists that
were sent to a place to investigate it
would have the wherewithal
to videotape this stuff.
And he said,
especially with this wormhole that he
reported where some being climbed out,
he said that uh,
the,
the energy that gets released from this
massive up cameras and of course the
moment you start hearing that stuff slide
right back down into the skeptic swamp
because it,
it does seem a little curious that a,
they don't have any
footage that I know of.
There might be footage,
there might be footage
from skin Walker ranch,
but I'm not aware of it.
Well,
it's sort of akin to how they
think that big foot consents,
camera traps.
Yes.
And that's where we're
getting to with the show.
Unfortunately there it's more of a show
in psychology than it is on anything
else.
Yeah.
As time goes on you realize that it's
more about how you sort of interpret what
you view in the world than it is
about what you're actually saying.
But look at the Phoenix Lights,
look at that.
What is that man?
That's some massive craft that went
flying over county after county.
Uh,
governor reported seeing it.
Come on man.
What is that?
That's not some kid
talking about wonder woman.
That's lots and lots of people
reporting the this thing.
Okay,
stop what you said there
because there is evidence,
video evidence in Phoenix Lights,
right?
Okay.
But what is the video evidence?
It's just these things floating in the
sky is red lights floating in the sky.
It's like very simple.
Sean descript.
Not that spectacular.
You can wash the Phoenix lights is
that they've shown it on national news
broadcasts and it's kind of nothing.
So all this other stuff is all stuff
that really wasn't captured on camera.
So it all falls into the
same category when you go.
What about the Phoenix Lights?
The governor saw it.
Everyone that you can get
all sensational with it.
But then when you go,
okay,
where is the evidence?
And you go,
well,
will they have a video?
And then you watched the
video of the Phoenix Lights.
You go man,
I mean,
what is that?
That ain't shit.
Let's pull up the fee.
Can you pull it up,
pull up the video of the Phoenix Lights,
find the video of the Phoenix Lights.
Let's just look at it
because it's stock footage.
Anyone can can look at it.
We'll pull it up because it's
something to behold because a,
it's it.
It's,
it's a huge point of
discussion in a Ufo Lore.
If you,
if you talk to people about there's
Roswell and the Phoenix Lights.
Yeah,
those are the two big ones.
Yeah.
But it is amazing when you
actually watch the Phoenix lights,
how non sensational it is,
how almost boring and nothing and
indescript it's just these floating light
bulbs.
Well,
yeah,
but I mean,
I think it,
to me the,
I mean,
I don't know,
it's to me what,
what your care is to me,
what,
but it does seem like it
could have been drones,
could have been a lot of things.
Let's watch it.
Okay.
This is the actual Phoenix lights and
this is the stuff that people talk about.
Like,
oh my goodness,
the UFO is are here.
We'll look at what we're actually seeing.
You actually seen some lights
floating above Phoenix.
Yes.
That's kind of interesting,
but you know,
it's not that interesting man.
I mean there's some lights
floating about Phoenix,
but those lights are connected.
I mean the idea is those lights
are connected to one crack.
No,
that's not the idea.
they are.
They see,
cause you see them,
there's this,
there's a bunch of them.
The idea is that there are
several different things going on.
Did these,
these things floating and it,
there's also this triangular
thing that's floating in the air,
but what you're seeing here is these
things that are floating in the sky and a
new one keeps lighting up.
My memory.
That is weird.
It is definitely weird,
but it's not something that human
couldn't do if we had drones.
I mean they keep popping up
and new light keeps popping up,
man.
Why?
If somebody is doing that as a hugs,
why didn't they keep doing it?
That's something crazy up there,
man.
It might not be a hoax it,
we might be experimented
with a new technology and
it wasn't far enough away to
be out of the view of the people.
It might be experimenting
with a psychology study to
see what would happen if
you have these uh,
non fon lights flying over a major
metropolitan city and in clear view of
everyone who lives there,
what's the reaction?
How do people,
how do people react to this?
What's the fallout?
That's it.
But I've seen videos of drones
going up in the air and they,
they,
Bob,
those things aren't bobbing right,
but what are they doing?
They're just sitting there.
They're sitting there,
which is even more bizarre.
I mean it,
yeah,
like how do you,
how do you do that?
Imagine the wind up that
high with something that
big to have stabilizers that
make it stay completely immobile.
Floating there in the sky.
If those were drones they would,
there were be movement that things
connected and the size of that thing is
tremendous.
Whatever that thing is is very,
very,
yeah,
it's moved up and down.
Those lights have moved up and down to me.
Like they're individually moving.
It looks like they're all
connected to one craft.
If you go back to the beginning though,
the way they are,
that's not in like one line.
In fact they're stacked on top
of each other a little bit.
Jamie ticket back to the,
to the very beginning if you would,
if you look at it very early on
when you start to see these lights,
they're not simply,
they're not simply all
along like a straight line.
Like one of them was above the other one.
Seems like there's two
on the right hand side.
Yeah.
That's that safe.
See that?
A bunch of them together.
See all that.
Yeah,
that's a curve.
Maybe,
maybe not.
Maybe it's like somebody released a
cluster of these drones and then they fly
out with these lights on
them and they stabilize.
Okay.
I think it's,
look,
I just from my UN scientific perspective,
that is those aren't drones.
I mean you can look up a video of drones
like flying at night floating and look
at what that looks like.
You should compare it to that because
I've seen this video of what drones are
balloons or a blimp,
but drones can take on a
million different forms.
I mean the idea that,
you know,
the word drone is like the word drug.
I mean,
it could be a,
could have a lot of different applications
to be a lot of different things.
Well,
look,
here's the,
here's the bottom line.
It's more likely that
that's a terrestrial craft,
right?
Then it's a non-terrestrial crap.
Right?
That's true.
You can't argue with that.
It's more likely that that's something
that the government created or someone
doing a hoax,
but the reports of that thing and
the distance that it traveled and the
consistency of the shape
and the many reports,
if that's a,
if that's a hoax,
it's an elaborate hoax.
Whoever's doing the hugs could probably
make a lot more money selling shit to
the government than freaking out rednecks.
Forgive me.
I don't think everyone in Phoenix,
Phoenix is not filled with hot.
There you go.
Nuts.
They're next door.
He returns to jam.
It can,
but they have air conditioning.
You know,
they're not savages.
Yeah.
But I know that if you have
to walk out to your car,
if you get sunstroke walking to your car,
you start slowly,
your brain fries a little bit.
Um,
didn't have stuff happened in September,
was relatively cool.
What's that?
Didn't this happen in September?
I don't know man.
For the sake of what I'm saying.
And he's happened in the middle of
summer when there's a power shortage.
Looking at,
here's the,
the,
what I'm saying is whatever that is.
It was novel and special
and Super Bizarre.
And what you're saying,
which is I think the best point is,
well,
where,
where's the footage from?
Skin Walker ranch?
Where's the footage?
Where's Bigelow's footage?
Where's footage of weird
things happening there?
This though this Phoenix lights,
if you keep watching this,
those lights just slowly fade out.
Which would sort of lend to the theory
that these were actually just flares.
No,
no,
that's just one shot.
Man,
I think traveled several counties.
There's videos of that thing all over fee.
That's not an
just from one spot I think move.
Okay.
Let's see if he got an,
uh,
look for best version of Phoenix Lights.
If you could find another one.
Jamey.
I think,
um,
I think it's,
uh,
it's something to think about.
You know,
the,
the idea,
something to think,
the idea that that was some sort
of an extraterrestrial spacecraft.
The decided to hover over Phoenix.
One thing that Eric Davis said,
which is interesting,
is that these beings,
whatever they are,
they're,
they're gathering intelligence.
They're trying to,
they're observing us.
For some reason.
They don't feel like necessarily
communicating with us.
They're observing us.
You know,
maybe they fuck up from time to time.
Maybe they screw up and,
uh,
something just crashes in Roswell or
something appears in the night sky and
nailing gets fired because he fell asleep
at the wheel or whatever they have.
Who knows?
Do you one better,
maybe their idea is that if you're dealing
with an incredibly intelligent human
being population that has nuclear power,
mass communications,
the ability to send video and
photographs through the air and,
and instantaneously
arrive across the globe.
Maybe these beings need to be baby fucked.
Maybe you need a slow Lee,
show them about Ufo,
a gentle,
gentle,
maybe you can't just just horse fuck.
Maybe he can't just like land on
the White House lawn and go eat,
come on bitches.
You're kind of with me.
And Start Zapping people.
Sure.
Maybe have to slowly
indoctrinate them into the idea
of the world of the extraterrestrial
intelligent being coming here.
And it's the way to do
that is to space it out.
The way to do that is to how
something happened in Roswell,
New Mexico.
And I mean,
again,
if you're talking about some infinitely
intelligent being Kurzweil's already
talking about extending our life,
that if you could live to 20,
45,
you know,
you're probably going to live forever.
You're going to live to a thousand years,
whatever you're dealing with a being that
has already accepted that as a reality
and it is planting a seed and it's slowly
planting a seed here on earth and that
allows those spacecraft to crash in a
place where it knows there's going to be a
military that's going to
be really quiet about it.
Sure.
And that they allow,
uh,
these,
these lights or they Cory GAF,
these lights flying over
Phoenix and landing.
Or maybe they know,
maybe they look at it like contamination.
You know,
like when we send the Mars probe
up to Mars and we try to keep it,
we try to like keep it from all earth
microbes to not contaminate Mars.
Maybe they look at it
showing and showing themselves to us
as a form of psychic contamination.
Maybe they don't want,
maybe they don't even
want us to know it all.
I think it's more likely if there are
these beings that they mess up just like
any other being does from time to time.
They just mess up.
There's mistakes and the
programs you workers.
Yeah.
Why not
this people they hire and they just do
a shit job of intergalactic travel to
like Shitty intergalactic
Greyhound bus drivers.
Yeah,
exactly.
Talk and look at the turnaround.
This is another video
of the Phoenix Lights.
Look at how stable those lights are,
man.
Yeah,
it is kind of interesting.
You know,
the idea of them being
stable as interesting,
but if we can split atoms with a bond
that would drop out of a propeller plane,
I don't think it's that,
that impossible to create something that
can hover in the sky like that and stay
stable in a straight line
look.
Of course,
of course.
Definitely.
There's no proof that that we
don't know where it came from.
All we know is that a massive thing that
seems to be a connection of lights on
some form of craft appeared over Phoenix
and it got caught on video by a lot of
different people.
We do know that.
So what that thing is,
who knows?
Comes Razor says it's the government
or it's some kind of military test or
something like that.
But you'd think of military test,
there's plenty of space to do that
shit where people don't see it.
Hmm.
And here's another,
let's throw this into the hat.
If you were an extraterrestrial
intelligent being and
you were coming here from
another planet to observe Earth,
where would you go?
Well,
I would want to go to
where this dude lives,
where he's making inflatable
bouncy houses for space.
Yeah.
I wanna I wanna check out that cat.
I want to go and,
and,
and freak out.
This dude who is got a billion ones and
Zeros and is spending all of it on Ufo
research and space travel research.
The problem with that is is he bought
the ranch from just cattle farmers.
So what sets up the activity was already
happening there before he bought the
ranch.
Yeah.
How much of that is horse poop?
How much that the,
the,
the activity before that?
It's not true.
Well I,
I don't know man.
But you know,
the difference between this and big
foot is that we already have much more
compelling footage than
we had for big foot.
I'm like just that.
It's like what is that?
And then of all the Ufo footage,
let's say that 2% of it is like that,
that's still pretty compelling.
Cause remembering,
I think it was in China or Japan,
I think it was China,
some giant craft started appearing.
And I think there's footage of that too.
This all seem to be happening at the
same time where people said maybe the
government's experimenting
with some massive,
uh,
stealth craft.
And it's also interesting that as our
technology is improving and our ability to
record things is improving subsequently.
Also,
our ability to fake things is improving,
right?
And you could,
you could fake it on a laptop.
A personal laptop can make
a very convincing video of
some paranormal activity,
whether it's a Ufo or a ghost,
or
you know,
name it well,
and even what's,
even if you experienced it yourself,
even if you're standing in Phoenix and
you look up and you see this thing go by,
you're still just dealing
with your optic nerve.
You're still dealing with
your limited human senses.
The truth is you'll never know.
You'll never know unless you got lucky
enough to get abducted and sucked into
one of these ships and saw for yourself.
There's no way that you can know
for certain what these things are.
We just know that is phenomena
that happens.
This is one of the things on the website,
uh,
the describes and skin
Walker ranch website.
The portal.
It says,
I have seen this firsthand,
but I have possibly seen radiation from
it made the entire night scenery appear
like daytime for 10 seconds.
Very bright flash of light,
which illuminated both sky and the ground.
First of all,
if you write like that,
I'm not listening to you.
Okay?
I have seen this firsthand,
but I have possibly
seen radiation from it.
That's a sentence.
Yeah.
What the fuck does that mean?
Dude,
I have seen this firsthand,
but I have possibly seen
radiation firsthand.
Yeah.
What the fuck are you saying?
Nothing.
Are you saying I haven't seen this first
hand or I have seen it says I have.
Oh,
it says,
I have never seen this.
I read it wrong.
So what?
Where's the picture?
Even if you did read her eye,
where's there's no picture,
there's no picture joking
around about the whole thing,
but because of buzz above
that is sent to Tiant missed.
Oh boy described by Bigelow researchers
as a neurological electricity.
That's unique.
Entity is completely black and
color takes the intangible for these
motherfuckers watched lost too many times.
It takes the intangible
form of a thick smoke.
The smoke is described like a disembodied
skin of a black electrified energy
that possesses and intellect theories
hold that this is a pre transitional
embodiment of a not yet formed entity
as it emerges from a portal or flashed
drone.
Oh,
excellent theory.
I'm sure peer reviewed,
I'm sure it's been peer reviewed.
This shameless,
malleable missed.
We'll eventually mold itself
into a local animal or humanoid.
A really does read like the
instruction guide for an Xbox game,
like these are the things
you're going to fight.
Exactly.
That's a video game.
I mean,
come on,
man.
It the smoke is eventually get a
mold itself into a local animal.
It's going to be a squirrel sylo squirrels
that you see that just like eating
nuts and you go,
hey Mr Squirrel,
that's an alien man.
He's spying on you from another planet
and sending data to the NSA of outer
space.
Yeah.
It's that website does
not seem very Kratovil.
Aw.
What we need to do,
man,
is we need to go to skin
Walker ranch ourselves.
We need to go and bring
some night vision equipment.
Scan the skies,
talk to the locals,
see if it's hooey.
Who knows,
man.
I mean it might be one of those
things where we get there.
We see a bunch of crazy shit.
Yes,
exactly.
That's the only way you
can know and never know.
You never know and at least we'll have
the experience that we could talk about
and everyone watching can
think that we're a too,
cause that's what happened.
Yeah.
That's the funny thing about it is we,
if we go there and have some
kind of experience and report it,
even if we catch it on camera,
there's still going to be selling me like,
Nah,
we're comedians.
Yeah.
What would they believe us?
They will.
Yeah,
exactly.
If you're not going to believe
is scientists working on
a warp drive or somebody
who's creating inflatable craft for NASA,
no one's going to believe to stoner comics
when they report and seeing flashing
lights.
Dude,
I swear we saw it.
By the way.
We have a new show coming out on PSI Phi.
It's called Joe Rogan questions.
Everything.
Duncan Trussell in ours fear.
What we're going to do is we're going to
try to find mysteries and we found one.
Yeah.
So what does music a real man,
Jesus could come climbing out of a hole.
It's skin Walker ranch
and give us both hand jobs
and,
well,
you know,
it's probably just a
hippie [inaudible] hippie.
I'm Jesus,
a clever gay hippie that climbs
out of squirrels asshole.
And he appears as missed
until he forms into Jesus.
The classic Jesus Robes,
hands outstretched.
He Chan has a cock in God.
Do you know how crazy that would be
if Jesus came back and was really gay?
Yeah.
If Jesus came back and just all
he wanted to do was give him jobs,
he didn't say,
we're amazing.
Yeah,
you would like,
you were really skeptical.
You're like,
why would I let them jerk me off?
Jesus.
You're not going to say now if
Jesus wants to give you a hand job,
you're not saying no.
We'd be like,
he'd be like,
listen,
I'll tell you all about spirituality
and enlightenment per first want to jerk
you off.
And when you're calm sprays out,
it turns into babies immediately.
No,
it's rainbows.
Oh yeah.
Just sparkling rainbows.
Smells the litter hours.
As soon as you come,
you're instantly as gay as Jesus.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean how do you go back?
It's hard.
Yeah.
When he jerks you off and it's
way better than sex with a woman,
you have a choice to make.
It's not even a choice.
Oh,
okay.
We have maps of skin walker,
ranch.org there's maps of where the
most activity is taking place Dunkin,
which is very important.
You know what the problem with a website
like that as once they've been talking
about some mess that can
congeal into an animal,
then everything else becomes invalidated.
It doesn't it.
It feels like whatever.
This website is not the
right place to go to.
Well,
if you ever seen how big
skin Walker ranch know,
it's enormous.
It's a,
I believe it's more than 2000 acres.
I think we should look at the Wikipedia
for skin Walker ranch before we look at
this freaks mushroom website because I
think Wikipedia has got a pretty accurate
description of what's going on.
It's going skin walk around.
Do they?
Yeah,
cause I looked it up.
Okay.
What does Wikipedia say?
I can't remember.
I,
my main understanding of skin
walker ranch comes from Dr. Eric Davis.
Okay.
Says,
according to local
legend Skin Walker ranch,
also known as Sherman ranch,
is a property located approximately
480 acres south east of Bowerbird,
Utah.
That is allegedly the site of
paranormal and Ufo related activities.
It's name is taken from the skin
Walker of native American legend.
Okay.
Let's see what the hell the skin walker,
has he ever heard of that?
Nope.
Okay.
Let's a skin walker,
boom,
boom.
And some native American legends.
A skin walker is a person
with the supernatural ability
to turn into any animal
he or she desires.
You know what that really is?
Why Pay Aod?
Yeah.
Right.
That's what that is.
Is their pay Odi out there?
Hell yeah.
Uh,
San Pedro,
Cactus Sun all day.
Okay.
To be able to transform legend
sometimes requires that the skin walker.
Where's a pelt of the animal though
this is not always considered necessary.
So they get high,
they see guy with a fur coat.
They think it's a bear.
We're out.
Sure.
Solve that one.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Native Americans,
you can drop the silliness.
Hey man,
back when you had no TV
and he did have payoti.
This is the kind of things
he believed claims about.
The ranch first appeared
in the Salt Lake City,
Utah Desert.
Deseret.
It says desert.
Brett says desert rat d s e r e t news.
Is that sounds right.
It is actually correct.
It's the Deseret news.
Hmm.
I wonder why they call it the
no,
it's the Deseret news.
Oh,
it's a Mormon term.
Deseret.
Some Mormon term.
Silly pitches.
Bunch of Voodoo fuckheads.
Anyway,
um,
first appeared claims about the ranch,
first appeared in Salt Lake City,
Utah,
Deseret news,
and later in alternative weekly Las
Vegas Mercury as a series of articles by
journalists.
George.
Now George snap is one of those guys
that's always involved in like Ufo stuff
and fringe stuff.
So Hey,
all of a sudden I'm going,
ah,
you know,
he's one of those area 51 dude's
nap and coauthor comb Kale.
Her subsequently authored a book.
Oh,
a book which they're selling,
which they described the ranch being
acquired by the National Institute for
Discovery Science Needs.
That's big.
Allow yes to study
anecdotal sightings of Ufos,
bigfoot like creatures,
crop circles,
ha,
glowing orbs and poltergeist activity
reported by its former owners.
The ranch located in.
Good luck with this one.
Ooh.
Ooh Wee wee into county to
winter.
Is that what it is?
I see it the winter.
Winter.
You sure?
Yeah.
Okay.
The ranch located in west Uintah county
bordering on the Indian reservation was
popular dub the Ufo ranch due to its
ostensible 50 year history of odd events
said to have taken place there.
According to these folks,
they saw or investigated evidence of
close to 100 incidents that include
vanishing and mutilated cattle sightings
of unidentified flying objects or orbs,
large animals with piercing yellow eyes,
paying odor that they say were not
injured when they were struck by boards.
That's the,
uh,
the bulletproof
and invisible objects admitting
destructive magnetic fields.
Among those involved the retired
army colonel John Be Alexander,
who characterize the needs effort as an
attempt to get hard data using standard
scientific approach.
However,
the investigators admitted to difficulty
obtaining evidence consistent with
scientific publication.
Yeah,
but that right there,
that admittance is what
lends them credibility.
The people who don't say stuff like that
or the people who you shouldn't trust.
But when you have scientists saying,
yeah,
we couldn't really find the evidence for
some reason it lends a little bit more
credibility to the two reports,
especially when one,
I talked to one of the scientists,
Dr. Eric Davis,
and he said that he saw something with
his own eyes and I really don't see why
that guy would have any
reason to lie to me.
Well,
I'm just skeptic James.
Randy awarded Bigelow a pig assists award
for funding purchase of the property
for what he termed a useless
study of a haunted ranch in Utah.
James,
Randy is like such a Douche.
Yeah,
I seems like it.
It seems like a real party pooper.
Yeah.
So what a party pooper man,
the guy wants.
Guy's got $1 billion once by a UFO ranch.
Why are you going to give him an award?
I'm going to give you the biggest
is towards a Pegasus is a pig.
That flight,
get it tongue in cheek when pigs fly
and it's awarded by noted skeptic James
Renner.
Well,
it shouldn't Randy be happy.
But when the scientist report that they,
there's,
they didn't find any.
No,
because his,
his ego is wrapped up and debunking thing.
Right.
And if he can like glow attention
to himself by giving out an award,
if they,
if you fos did exist
and he found evidence,
he'd probably like sweep it under the rug.
Right.
How's it?
Let's see here.
Yeah,
keep the foundation going.
Yeah.
Right.
You know,
I mean obviously probably not.
Probably be shitting his
pants and start apologizing.
Yeah.
Probably be like,
it would be like a psychedelic experience.
It depends on what kind of alien it was.
Well,
if it was like some close encounters
of the third contact shit,
that would be a pretty
soggy dog experience.
If a gigantic duty,
if that just
hovered over the desert floor
and these little tiny dudes,
giant heads and big black eyes
came out and started talking to us.
What'd you get on the ship?
Nope.
I think that's the funniest thing.
That guy just gets onboard.
That's so stupid.
Why would you do that?
Then?
You're stuck with these
little assholes forever.
Even at your jokes.
Jokes.
That's how they go hunting.
Does no comedy clubs in space.
They probably don't have
any porn and if they did,
it's them fucking,
and the way they fuck is
probably with their fingers.
They probably handshake each other
and fall down spasm and orgasm.
They're big heads.
The reason why they're big heads,
the outside of it as a cushion for when
they black out and they shake hands and
come,
they fall.
They're big heads bounce like a fucking
book below and it's to protect their
brains inside Donk,
donk,
donk.
It's like a ball bouncing.
You wouldn't get on a ship.
No fucking way.
I'd like people.
I'm really happy.
I'm a person and I like people.
I don't need to go to space.
I think it'd be cool to see it.
I'd be,
it'd be cool to like look at the shit,
but what have you going to
take me like a monkey in a zoo?
Do you think those chimps want to
be in the zoo the fuck they do?
Of course they don't.
And why would they differentiate between
the way we treat intelligent animals
like dolphins and throw him
in a fucking swimming pool?
Why would they decide to treat us so
much better than the way we've treated
everything that we see?
Right.
You think when at Dolphin
ends up on a seaworld bout,
it thinks it's the same as being on a
Ufo and it's super intelligent name on
mine.
It's probably like these
on wonderful beings.
They're taking me to paradise.
The next thing you know,
they spit it out in some piss out pool.
Are they going to do flips for toddlers?
Exactly.
When w you know,
we,
we see a mountain lion eat a dog
and we shoot that mountain lion.
We justify murdering the Sanama
because this animal murders,
if we see us imprisoning dolphins,
if these aliens see us in prison dolphins,
why wouldn't they imprison us?
Oh,
these guys are dicks.
Maybe aliens only should go to seaworld
and the zoo and just scoop up zookeepers
and trainers take those finance,
all the,
all the kids clapping their hands as these
super intelligent beings that used to
be able to swim through an infinite,
practically infinite sea with their
tribe and their family are now like doing
embarrassing tricks for fish,
for shitheads.
It's the worst of the worst.
So I,
I wouldn't get on board.
That's how I'm feeling.
There's no way I wouldn't even think
about getting on board if they landed and
they like,
would you like to come with
us to another galaxy table?
Like a bitch?
Get the fuck out of here.
Like driving now man,
you've given a good marriage.
So do you think that's what
it was at Richard Dreyfus?
He didn't really,
wasn't really a good his family.
And he was like,
fuck these kids,
I'm going to get on board.
It's the ultimate thing cause he knows
he's wanting to get a divorce and he just
says thinking,
do I want to go through
divorce proceedings or fly
to Alpha Centauri with these
watermelon heads.
Do you know that Steven Spielberg said
that if he made them moving today after
having children,
he would do it differently.
What would he do?
He wouldn't leave his children and that
he wouldn't have had Richard Drivers get
on board the space ship.
And that was something
that a single man would do.
And that a,
a person who has children wouldn't do.
And that to me makes all
the sense in the world.
Sure.
Cause that's,
that's,
I kind of thought that when
I watched it I was like,
man,
I got just leaving his kids.
Like that's kind of fucked up.
Give me a break man.
There was a lot of guys
who walk into casinos,
like drive his,
walked into that Ufo.
Yeah.
They just go wandering in
with a smile on their face.
Cla Or brats.
I'm going to the slots.
That's true.
They me,
me,
meaning Ding,
Ding,
Ding.
And really kind of similar.
That's an alien environment as well.
Yeah.
I mean,
where do you ever get that
many electronic noises?
All screaming at you,
man trap.
Yeah.
It's like when you lay out
traps for rats with cheese,
that's tourists.
Every fucking one of them has like a
video screen above it with dancing girls
and tight dresses and everyone's
cheering when the money flows.
Famous
TV shows.
It's very,
very hypnotic.
I've thrown money into the slots.
When I go to vague,
I said,
grabs my attention.
Yeah,
and it's somehow calming,
like it's fills up so many of your
senses that it really is like a weirdly
calming experience to gamble.
Right?
Yeah.
For a lot of folks,
it's incredibly intoxicating too because
it goes back to that hunter gatherer
thing,
but we don't have any
real risk in our lives.
We don't have any real
immediate risk reward.
There's a life and death
aspect to losing $1,000.
Right?
You're like,
oh my God,
that's a,
it's a month of my life or
that's a week of my life saving.
You know,
he like,
if you think about how much money can
you save in a month for most folks that
are kind of getting by,
if you could save $1,000 a month,
that's pretty damn good.
That's put away 12 grand
a year for most folks.
That's pretty good.
So you're really losing a month of your
life when you gamble or possibly gaining
a month.
It's a month and I couldn't
be better this month.
I got by a car.
Yeah.
There's a life or death aspect
of that that plays upon that.
The same instincts.
Yep.
They're not being fueled
by this nerved out world.
Yeah.
It's,
yeah,
you're right,
man.
You're right.
We long for something.
Yeah,
it's true.
But I,
you know,
man,
I don't,
after talking to Eric Davis
and when you see the footage,
you might think I'm an idiot.
You might just decide
that the guys and is,
uh,
not,
not on the beam so to speak.
But I really,
uh,
I dunno,
I,
when you have somebody tell you that
they've seen lights hovering lights,
I don't know.
I guess I'm just naive
because I just pulled,
I believed him.
I get it.
Right.
You didn't feel like he was lying and
it felt legitimate to me and it wasn't
even,
look,
if you're going to lie about a Ufo story,
make it big.
Right.
You know why?
Just say,
yeah,
I saw hovering lights.
I don't think that those
lights could have been a hoax.
I have no way to explain it,
you know?
Yeah.
I just didn't feel like
I was being lied to.
Well,
I mean,
that's interesting because that's the
same feeling that we had when we talked to
that woman Barbara,
in the corner store in Washington when
she was talking about Sasquatch and our
siding.
It sounds completely ridiculous
if you look at it on paper.
When that woman was talking to us,
we were like,
wow,
she is believable in
a very odd way that I,
I didn't expect anyone to be believable.
Everybody else told me that Ufo stories,
and I was like,
Oh yeah,
okay.
Does that happen?
Hmm.
Okay.
Thank you for your story.
But I was like,
this is a little hole.
But she was talking and I was like,
whoa.
You know,
and I was sober.
So that's,
that means a lot.
Yeah,
man.
When this Eric Davis
and a really accurate,
precise way describe the math that
would go into creating a warp drive and
explained wormholes and then pointed out
all these experiments that were getting
no results and then told me that he had
seen hovering lights and made me believe
him,
I believe.
I think he saw something out there.
I don't think it's improbable
that something's out there.
Maybe it's a natural occurrence.
Why not?
Maybe you know,
certain parts of the Earth have a tendency
to create very rare phenomena that
humans tend to ascribe
as being alien who has,
maybe it is ball lightning ready.
We'll go out there and
just see ball lightning.
You know what?
I've never seen ball lightning.
I'd love to.
That would be very cool if we went out
there and just got ball lightning on
film.
I would be psyched.
Yeah.
I don't even know how you
would differentiate between
that and the UFO though.
We would probably cry UFO first.
We would definitely cry you if I
were going to say we saw a Ufo.
If a bird phone,
let's just start lying.
Just like they do.
We should start doing the convention
circuit hooking up with Ufo believers.
We've got to get together in the hotel
before and get our story straight and
you're like,
don't man.
I'm tired of being anal probed.
Let's leave that out.
Yeah.
I don't want to talk about that,
but listen,
today we can't do that because in Utah
we talked about anal probing and a little
thing called the internet.
So Nevada,
you have to,
yeah.
Wow.
Why did you say that now?
It didn't stick to that permits the Lore.
I went with the folk.
Lord didn't go with the law.
You.
It's embarrassing.
It's,
it's in my mind.
I did well.
Why'd you say you liked it?
I didn't say I liked her.
I saw,
I love that.
Let's go to a skin walker ranch.
Ben.
Cool scope.
We're going to go.
We're going to set up cameras.
We're going to bring technology,
we're going to bring our
friend Donnie who has drones,
are going to try to get the
drones to fly over the property.
Cool.
Only the legal parts where
it's legal to fly over.
Yeah.
Great.
See something cool.
Cool.
Cause I've never done
anything like that in my life.
Like I've gone out and laid in a yard.
I've gone out in the forest and looked
up in the sky for a few minutes,
but I've never actively
tried to have a Ufo sighting.
Well maybe [inaudible] it if
you believe Dr. Steven Greer,
he thinks you can summon them.
Really?
How intent.
Oh really?
Focusing in a tent and they just go,
hey,
wow man,
that must be why he has all that
amazing footage of the U of m.
So convenient.
Yeah,
he does hours of it was very convincing,
very convincing.
That's why he changed the world.
He's got fucking birds and night vision.
There's a guy named Ryan Skinner and uh,
we're going to meet him there and he's
been studying skin walker ranch and he's
going to show us the INS and out and
sort of give us a sense of what other
people have seen there,
how much of it's hooey and what
he really believes is going on.
Cool.
Skin Walker ranch baby.
Here we come.
Can't wait.
Bring sunscreen.
Does it get hot out there?
I am.
Well No,
I'm saying for the electric magnetic
radiation from the wormholes,
the sunscreen protects you from that
little thin film of oil and it gets zapped
by the,
the glow around a magnetic field
of a flying disc and you're fine.
Who knows?
Man,
you know,
there is some small chance that they're
going to find is camera equipment
scattered everywhere or just withered
up husks our mouth open when Anna scream
frozen from something that emerged.
Yeah,
just like cattle mutilations.
Yeah.
That would be incredible.
If they had academy inhalation,
but it was a person instead of a
cattle and the same things were done,
there will be a real problem.
Have you ever looked at some
of those cattle mutilations?
It's really good.
It's really freaky stuff.
Regarding the cattle mutilations,
Eric Davis said that they studied this
stuff and they said it seems to be being
done by humans again man.
When when people are
Kooks everything's aliens,
right?
When you hear somebody say no,
that wasn't a,
that was,
it seems to be like a,
he said that the cuts were done more by
a scalpel than the lasers that people
report and it seemed to be terrestrial,
whatever.
You know,
it's a weird thing.
Who knows what people are doing it,
but the fact is this guy was
willing to say that's not aliens.
So that to me lends credibility to his
report of having seen aliens out there.
Interesting.
Great stuff.
Do you think that if we
got roasted by aliens,
Psi Phi would be happy or sad?
They'd be happy.
Yeah.
An alien rose will be amazing.
Not like,
not like the friars club and
that's what I was thinking.
I was thinking it'd be like,
like a roast.
Like we sit on the DAS and
they'll come up and go,
here's the funny thing
about Duncan Trussell.
A lot of people don't know that.
Under that Fedora is an
inflatable alien hat crop circle.
He wants to pretend it's a bald spot.
It's actually a fairly accurate depiction
of all his favorite crop circles
carved into his head.
All right,
we're going to go skin walker ranch,
boom.
Let's see what's happening.
Great.
What do you think going to be successful?
Yes,
ma'am.
I think it's,
I think,
yes.
I think we're going to see something.